and now a word from our sponsor
betterhelp betterhelp is customized
online therapy that offers videophone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with the
therapist in under 48 hours that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash trash tuesday this podcast
is sponsored by better help and trash
tuesday listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday i am so pleased to
announce that our show is sponsored by
liquid death listen to this
is there a better sound
you guys can get free shipping on all
water and merch at liquid death dot com
slash trash that's liquid death dot com
slash trash or find liquid death at 711
target albertson safeway or amazon um i
have been having such a fun time on the
road i love meeting all of you guys it's
like insane so much crazy things so many
crazy things happening during the shows
it's incredible you can see me august
12th through 13th in springfield
missouri at the blue room comedy club
it's gonna be amazing i love that club
you can then see me in september i'll be
in pittsburgh tempe arizona
la jolla comedy store i'll be at the
caluso casino in california you guys
that is going to be so fun party without
a casino please god that is so fun then
uh later dates i'll be in kansas city
irvine san jose
michigan
and florida and you can go to
andyletterman.com shows to get it also
please tune in to my spotify live show
every monday at
5 p.m pst 8 p.m eastern it's so fun it's
an interactive audio show where it's
called don't bore me with annie
letterman it's your chance to entertain
me it's been so fun
and i can't wait to talk to you on there
hi you guys i am coming back on the road
and you can get tickets at
estheronics.com i'm coming to dc austin
phoenix seattle and portland i'm very
excited for these shows they're going to
be really
[Music]
that's special a tattoo that's
imagine this was a tattoo it's like an
intervention like annie the lip liner
yeah honestly if you're gonna put it on
you may as well just tattoo it on
it it feels like a tattoo i feel like it
feels like my like i killed someone in
juvie or something it looks like my
teardrop tattoo
that's a green flag for me when a guy
has a teardrop tattoo oh interesting
i've never heard him remind you of her
family girlfriend
are you familiar with the term green
flag like the opposite of a red flag
okay i understand
i mean
i honestly thought there was another
explanation for it and that you weren't
that's good this is esther explaining
that's when it's something everyone
already knows it's very simple and i get
to feel smart for i learned it on tiktok
so a teardrop tattoo is a green flag
yeah didn't you say anthony
that i understand
that when you see someone with a
teardrop tattoo that that is someone you
actually want to engage with rather
rather than run away from no if i saw a
teardrop any face tattoo it's got to be
that's a choice
i'm not like oh i'm attracted to that
person because of their face tattoo guys
well there's one specific face tattoo
that means a lot which is the teardrop
so that means you've murdered someone it
does
yeah oh my god esther
esther's first day in school guys i
don't think it always means you murdered
someone it could be like your morning
i've heard people get it when like
someone close to them dies
that's
so confusing carlos pull it up i'm not a
murderer i'm just sad
oh as much as i don't want to reveal
about myself that i'm actually white
trash or half white trash
my grandma has eyeliner tattooed on to
her eyes that's not this is not white
trash that's also very asian
yeah all asian women have tattooed
eyebrows like older asians no eyeliner
did i have an eyeliner sorry and
eyeliner that's just like a time saver
it's not even really a tattoo yeah yeah
i know esther's like i don't want to
brag my family's so hardcore we're like
i don't want to waste anything
but i am like what does that say about
my genetics that my grandma tattooed
eyeliner like are we like hoes or
something
i think just lazy
honestly i would love for you to tattoo
some [ __ ] eyeliner or something come
in with something i'll pay for it
honestly i'll pay for your whole i want
you to get um
tattoo contour oh
esther do you want to introduce our
guests so today we have anthony jeselnik
welcome to our show thank you for having
me um big fans of the justin nick
rosenthal vanity project just licking
rosenthal vanity project jrvp you sound
like a big fan
i really am carlos and i listen to it um
carlos got me into it because he's
secretly a super fan yeah i give her
updates
cool um on the way to san diego
yesterday um bobby and i was getting
ketamine assisted psychotherapy for the
very first time
um
we
he we listened to you on the whole way
over there oh cool yeah and then not on
the way back after the ketamine she was
like i can't handle this
well it was you and then brian eno and
then ketamine
so how do you feel kalylah you're still
attracted to murders it hasn't changed
you that much i'm still buffering i i i
don't even drink coffee and i did
ketamine yesterday and i wasn't i was
slammed into a k hole i don't know if
you guys know what that is but
boy do i what was it was i don't want to
call it bad or good but i was [ __ ]
frightened i thought i was dying
so i'm gonna leave it at that i'm so
excited but is it is it helpful like
ketamine's one of those drugs i don't
even understand what it is or what it
does ketamine is a dissociative drug so
when it enters your system you're kind
of detached like it almost feels like
it's an out-of-body experience you feel
you don't feel any pain i wouldn't call
it a full like hallucinogenic because
it's not like when people like see
things when they're on mushrooms and
they're euphoric
it's more like a
for me it was
going it was when they say k-hole i was
in the hole i was seeing cave after cave
after mossy cave
and i was i thought i was dying was she
asking you like and then the doctor
touched you here i couldn't speak i
didn't asking you things though no i
couldn't i didn't even have a single
linear thought i just had
so much feelings and i was crying and i
was clutching her for 90 minutes
you were clutching her
yeah she was like i'm gonna get a [ __ ]
lying on a table or yeah it's like a
moon pod you put your um
your little eye mask on and then the
music and i started off with
high hopes just like this and very soon
i was in a fetal position like clutching
the therapist but there's an a doctor
there as well um for the whole 90
minutes he was an er doctor so i felt
like oh this is a safe experience but
even then i thought i was dying whoa was
it fun yeah
does it sound funny
like when it's over do you feel better
is it like almost like doing mushrooms
when it's done you feel kind of like a
weight is taken off you it feels
i i don't know yet like i'm still
buffering um but the reason that i chose
ketamine is because of its anti-anxiety
and anti-depressive properties and they
say like it those can last up to a whole
year wait you guys that's so interesting
like are you you're not
i feel like you're not on
antidepressants
no you do seem like a candidate is that
okay to say it's because you just stand
up
that's
the darkness you
unleash yeah people always think that
that's like a sign of something i've had
people flat out ask if i'm a psychopath
but no you have a good kind of like dead
face too poker face yeah resting [ __ ]
face are you good at are you good at
poker
no i get bored so i just go all in
really quickly
[Applause]
that's what i would do too yeah
let's either end this or let me get out
of here
oh my god wait have you ever done like a
psychedelic or anything like that yeah
i've done uh mushrooms i just asked it a
couple times i was done martha's
vineyard for a summer and someone got
acid we trusted it and like every couple
days we would do like a hit or two and
like run around jump off bridges and
[ __ ] it was fun but at the end i was
like i don't know if i would trust it
again but i enjoyed it yeah the bridge
would probably be the part i wouldn't
trust yeah
a lot of people were doing that who even
weren't on drugs it was really fun uh in
the middle of the night but i every
couple years
every couple years i'll do mushrooms
someone described it as cleaning your
windshield yeah that's why i wonder like
if ketamine's like that that it's like
you feel like you're just you've got
your car washed and you kind of have a
burden lifted off of you that mushrooms
can be like that but it's been years
since i've done this sometimes mushrooms
don't do that for me though it's like i
either do too much or too little
sometimes where it's like
i just get uncomfortable or i'm like you
kind of like start thinking about
the fact that everyone around you is
gonna die and you're gonna die and stuff
and then you don't really like go into
it and then you're just stuck with the
creepy feeling of it
has anyone watched that show on netflix
that just came out with michael pollan
had to change your mind yeah i've been
watching it with the masculine
psilocybin all of that yeah lsd
it's just gotten me very curious about
like these kinds of experiences because
they talk about how like like what
you're saying like it just frees up your
brain and opens you up and like clears
you out well if you think about like
anxiety right think of how much of your
time before you were on meds and stuff
was just like spinning spinning spinning
when there's like what else could you be
doing if you weren't
worried about like
whatever
for me the ketamine was now in
retrospect the correct drug of choice
because it made me realize that like i
have no sense of retreat or surrender
i tried to fight out of this experience
the whole time there was no minute of
like
relax and let go and that says a lot
about who i am there is absolutely no
surrender in who i am and on top of that
i've never felt a single minute of
safety in my life
so like those are the two downloads
those seem to go together
so it hasn't been an easy thing like i i
was hot everyone was like you're gonna
love it i came out of there like what
the [ __ ] were they talking about don't
you think you went in with an
expectation and that's what you're
worried about instead of just because
it's still working on you you know it's
still working on you you look younger
the expectation was i'm gonna need
healing around this breakup and
self-love no it did not go there and
they were like you're gonna get shot up
into space it shot me straight down to
hell
that's what it is
it's so funny to me that you would want
me on this podcast
that you like stepped out of academy you
were like i hope anthony's here
i feel like you're thinking i want to
hurt you when i get out of my presence
you know when we talked outside like it
yes it it does i i really really am
happy you're here today yeah i think
you're the correct person to be in front
of me after being in a k-hole that long
when you got out of the pod was it like
like bobby and jules were just right
there they came you know when i got out
of the pod the first thing they handed
me was a banana and i was happy oh thank
you thank you for this banana break but
i had a question for you what do people
do in martha's vineyard
i mean besides acid
there were like two classes of people
it's like people who are there to work
which i was one of people who work in
the restaurant service industry and then
people who are there on vacation or and
then there's people who live there which
is like a different kind of class of
people but i was 20 years old so i
couldn't go to bars so i was kind of
just stuck doing you know what the
people who weren't going to bars were
doing which was a lot of weed and just
hanging out barbecuing and someone got
acid great but it was just a really fun
kind of hippie-ish time were you a good
waiter
i was i worked in the kitchen my friends
were waiters and they made so much more
money yeah but i just got to hang out in
the i worked on the cold line at the
seafood shanty oh i love seafood shanty
love seafood shanty yeah it was it was a
really fun a really fun summer yeah i
can't believe you're just like yeah i
did like acid and jumped off bridges i'm
like i don't know what to say to someone
who tells like that's so scary
it was like a very high bridge it was
like you just jumped right into the
water and then swam to the shore and did
it again but there were like kids doing
it you know 20 feet away from us oh okay
does that change
i still wouldn't have done it but i'm
just like wow if a kid taller than you
came and did it would you be and that
that would not change no my niece is
taller than me i see her but do you
think remember yesterday when you were
like i realized that it feels or last
week sorry uh that it feels good to do
something that you were scared of
totally do you think maybe bridge
jumping's in your future no
it's too far what's the most accident
i was gonna say what about acid in your
future is acid and lsd the same thing
yes it is
based on like the science that they talk
about in that show like maybe i would i
liked acid more than mushrooms mushrooms
kind of make you sick like it is a
poison a natural poison whereas acid you
kind of get the trip but you don't feel
that like that nauseousness that you
feel on mushrooms did you have like the
thing that they were talking about in
this documentary where like everything
is like melting and like did you have
that psychedelic experience
a little bit but it was mo i didn't take
that much so it was more just like you
had this burst of energy and things were
fun but faces would get weird uh you
would stare at the ocean for a long time
i remember at the i took my first time i
ever took it i took a hit of acid i got
off work early earlier than my other
friends it was me and this other guy
took a hit acid we're having fun and
then when my friends got off work at
night i took another one thinking it was
like beer like i'll have another one and
i'll keep going but i had a different
trip than everyone else and so i was
kind of like really tired just a little
out of it and my other friends were just
like laughing and having fun and i'm
like waiting for this trip to end and we
go to this diner the uh the black dog
diner i think it was called it's like
the famous they people see sweatshirts
all the time i think that's what it's
called
and i'm like i think i'm finally done
tripping i'm sitting in a booth with my
two friends this woman behind me this
old woman sitting by herself
i just kind of out of the corner of my
eye i see her and she goes to take a
bite of a bagel and it looked like her
jaw unhinged
and i was like so freaked out i was like
nope still
tripping
looking at old people when you're
tripping is really hard i remember my we
some girl when i used to live in santa
fe some girl gave me like a pill bottle
filled with mushroom shake like it was
just like little pieces of it so i don't
know why i thought if it's chopped up
it's not gonna be
anything oh my god so my friends and i
are at my friend and her mom were going
to meet us and it was me and my two
friends and
we sprinkled it over our pizza at this
bar and
i mean the whole thing we're just like
whatever we're eating the pizza
my friend shows up with her mom and we
lost our [ __ ] minds like her mom sat
down her mom was like an older mom she
had already had wrinkles and my friend
just went your face is made of ropes and
it was like we gotta go we gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here i feel like i was
always like the person
i was always trying to like if the cop
showed up to a party i was always the
one like
trying to manage it yeah trying to make
the parents think everything was fine
i'm just curious like do you because the
way that they make lsd sound on this
show is that like it opens your mind
that you just watched this this is the
first time you're learning about it
you're calling it lsd everything you're
doing is so
is it is she esther's esther's
graduated fifth grade guys
we should have like a sixth grade dance
for you
she just started smoking weed this year
we're proud of her it is good i'm happy
i love a sixth grade dance at the comedy
store i would love that
no one would dance it's just even benji
i make carlos dance with me but he has
to like go away from a girl he likes
anthony how were you at that school
dances would you dance or would you kind
of be in the corner i was like everybody
else where it was like guys on one side
girls in the other and then the last
song with the last slow song everyone
would dance and then you'd be like oh
it's over it's like you've had hours
and then you'd go home yeah everyone why
does that happen [ __ ]
because you're building up you're
finally getting there i think you warm
up you see everyone doing it and by the
time you actually like you know get the
courage to get out there it's done i
know it and it's like you're nerve
you're at the most like insecure time of
your life when you're afraid of people
looking at you and this is the one dance
where everyone is [ __ ] looking at you
like if no one's dancing yet it's like
did you guys have this i've heard this
is a common experience about senior year
of high school that like at the very
last few weeks of it you start to like
get to know
your classes better than you ever would
yeah i did that like i remember the last
few weeks of high school like
having real conversations with people
who i never really well is that is that
because everyone's signing each other's
yearbooks and like you're passing that
around no i think it's you're like oh
i'm never really gonna see this person
again i might as well be like hey like
you took them for granted all right it's
just like two people that never we were
in the same class but we never like made
the effort i don't know where did you go
to high school what was that like for
you i went to a public school uh in the
suburb of pittsburgh called upper
sinclair and it was like a graduating
class of 300 and i went to that school
from like first grade through through
high school oh so you've known people so
first grade through high school so
that's a k to 12 so you know kids from
when from kindergarten
that went through the whole thing first
grade yeah yeah i had that too
oh wow what's that like
you can ask him
you were used to it that the other way
would have been weird and people would
yeah the catholic school would come into
our school for high school yeah um but
it was it was normal
get to bang them on the butt
it is like i always think about that
with like the comedian lisa traeger who
that does stand up but like i'm i do
think like we were on the same school
bus
it's so weird together like to an
elementary school wait you were yeah but
i feel like you sat up front to talk to
the driver to make sure everything was
safe
she was like smoking weed in the back i
do always i did always feel like the
driver wanted to [ __ ] me i know that's
so weird to say and i was like ted the
least weird thing you've ever said
you definitely did but um
yeah no like just it is it's a different
experience when you you've known someone
since they were
trying to [ __ ] a little kid yeah i
don't know do you still talk to the bus
driver we text she's like finally
someone's trying to [ __ ] me
i can't let him go did you go to prom
yeah yeah
i went to prom
i was the uh students against drunk
driving class president oh my god
yes excuse me what were you why why how
did that happen because i i was like
kind of panicked about getting into
college because i i [ __ ] around all
through high school and everyone's like
you're going to regret this when it
comes time to apply to schools so senior
year i was like now i've got to like do
it all and the only club like i tried to
join all the clubs but the only club
that had its election senior like at the
beginning of the year instead of like
the end of the previous year was sad
and uh
and so i had all my friends my sisters
were in high school with me and i had
them bring all their friends to the
meeting and everyone's going to vote for
me
and there's three people running and one
guy gets up and he's like i think i'd be
a good president everyone's like yeah we
don't even know who you are and then a
girl gets up
and starts crying talking about some one
of our family members getting killed by
a drunk driver she really wants to
change it
and then i stood up and i'm like so i've
i've been gone drinking and driving
before it's like you know i so i know
what it's like and i can help i think
that way and everyone's in shock but i
won by a landslide because i stacked the
audience
and so my friends gave me a flask that
said upper sinclair sad president i have
a question um you're obviously a very
handsome man this pretty privilege oh my
god somebody's saying that um
it's pretty privileged apply
this pretty privilege apply there like
you know pretty privileged with girls
and stuff
esther don't look at me like this is a
[ __ ] term i just made up well it just
became she just got pretty so i'm
honestly just thinking that that was
more like his origin story from how he
became a comedian because it's like
someone went up and had this like tragic
story and then you were like
[ __ ] it and that feels like like the how
your jokes are right
kind of i mean i'd already planned my
speech for the sad president thing that
i was like i don't know how to ad-lib
this you know and i i was committed um
it was just kind of a funny story at the
time but uh
um so for prom i had to be
uh i had to be i couldn't i wasn't
supposed to drink at prom everyone was
kind of looking at me and uh and then
after after prom they had this thing
called after prom so instead of kids
going off and getting wasted in the
cabin somewhere they had a thing that
was at school where everyone oh dave and
buster's where all the students went and
if you were on student council you had
to go to it or you couldn't graduate and
my girlfriend was on student council so
i had to go and we dr we put um vodka
and gatorade bottles
and pounded it right before we went in
and we'd all been up for days because
it's like the end of school you're just
having fun with your friends and so i
just went to sleep on a table and the
parents thought i was like passed out
drunk which i kind of was but i was also
very tired and they picked me up and
carried me around and made me walk in a
circle for hours of after prom like i'm
just like stump i don't barely remember
and he never let anyone else roll over
him again
i was angry about that
[Music]
and now a word from our sponsor better
help
you guys life can be overwhelming and
many people are burned out with that
they don't even know it i know it
i'm very aware of how burnt out i am
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless or trapped detachment
fatigue and more i know i have felt all
of these things and when you don't know
what's going on in your head and you're
just so overwhelmed it's hard to it's
hard to get out of your loop or your
cycle and sometimes you need like
someone else to look at your life and
listen to you and
in order to like snap out of whatever
you're dealing with for me therapy has
been an indispensable part of my life
because um i
had someone help me name it
so i could claim it and then change it
and i honestly like it's as simple as
that that's
when yeah it's some simple as someone an
unbiased ear being like okay let me help
you name that thing that you're feeling
so you can
claim it so you know you're not afraid
of this thing that you're feeling and
then you know change it if it needs to
be changed and you know we associate
burnout with work but that's not the
only cause any of our roles in life can
lead us to feel burned out and better
help online therapy wants to remind you
to prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to and it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours from right now this
podcast is sponsored by a better help
and trash tuesday listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash trash tuesday
[Music]
as president of students against drunk
driving like what do you organize like
what do you what do you do
they i mean i wasn't there very long
like i didn't go to a lot of meetings um
and uh they they wanted to do lock-ins
so they called it where you would go to
the high school and then have bands play
like high school bands would play and
kids would come so it was like keep kids
off the streets oh i see it away from
drinking and just hang out i don't know
if we ever did it i was really
traumatized at our lock-in have i ever
told you what is the lock-in oh my god
can i just wait
esther all she wants is sleepovers like
she's so full of [ __ ] she wants people
to invite her to things that she can say
no to is what it is let me know you
finally got your school sleepover what
happened no it's so bad okay
why did i
oh just be yourself okay so basically
what happened was is have i ever told
you guys about the sex tape i made in
high school right yes okay so
maybe you have until it was with the bus
driver anthony
he wishes
[Laughter]
listen bus driver okay so just like
bringing the bus driver that got away
that drove away the one that jumped away
so
my freshman year of high school before
school started there was like a football
game and i was on vaiquettes you know
palms and so only freshman year
um
and i went to the football what is the
vike hats
i was on vicodin
high school experiences
so
i met
these two girls at a football game and
like we just met and one of us i don't
really remember who said it but was like
we should have a sleepover
and like so we asked our parents and we
got to go have a sleepover and then like
that's like the night where like we made
this like sex tape whatever i don't need
to get into it it's with two girls they
need a sex tape yeah this is the first
one you're not the second surprise
at that annie remember there are
multiple sex tapes
it's just so sad how hard you tried to
be like
how hard i tried to be hot
but so anyways so i really didn't mean
to do this okay so anyways
sex tape happens the next day happens to
be the lock-in i feel like you skipped
the step
[Laughter]
so we just sleepover sex tip happens
yeah what's going on so the three of you
what we have to say that for another
time i i it's true no no no no no no no
you guys are this is
i'm into it
that's his thing that's why we invited
him but anyways what happens is at the
lock-in
i'm like oh my god like we just all did
this like we're [ __ ] so close now
they didn't hang out with me at the lock
and it was really traumatic
and were you pounding on the door let me
out
why'd you cry why do you think what what
what move do you
did you run it back in your head like
what did i do wrong i think they had
like more friends at the lock-in that
they were excited about like to them
like the sleepover sex tape name was
just like another night
what happened in the sex tape esther you
were you i was used
to fine i understand you're so much
better now wait esther no no no what
happened with the how did it start who
figured who is the question this isn't
like we didn't have iphones back in the
day it's like you had to get like a no
yeah there was a camcorder she pulled
out a camcorder she did i don't wanna
and this is just getting too traumatic
anthony our co-worker is here at the
comedy store
what are your thoughts she's a bad
storyteller
she's not that like the only good part
and she and you introduced you like did
i ever tell you guys about the sex tape
well i'm gonna leave out the sex tape
but tell you the rest of it
there's a rejection around it cause
that's all that matters to her it's true
she's in it for the beating after yeah
for them did you make your mom mommy
come pick you up you were like mommy i
made his
sexy tape with them and now they don't
like me do you think maybe it was like
they didn't like what they saw
once they saw your naked they're like
not as good as i thought
yikes
you
want to go home
did you have a big bush then too oh my
god annie but did you
no it wasn't that bad then
do you know bobby said he didn't get his
first pube until he was 16. until he was
50 years old and then
it fell off but then he he felt very
attached to it so he saved it it escaped
it was trying to get away from bobby so
he saved it and then i guess his mom
accidentally vacuumed it and he was
really upset about it because that was
the only like that was his only evidence
of like you know
manhood finally like studying in
that was a story
well i'm gonna tell you he's gonna be
real upset when someone vacuums you up
[Laughter]
you're about to get a vacuum up girl
[Laughter]
i love that you guys had like high
school it's so fun i was it was recently
brought to my attention because
it's only building what's going on out
there about us
it's only growing um someone sent me a
link to a clip there's like these two
guys that like make fun of
stuff
and they refer to me casually as the
girl that does nothing
i was like dave dave come in here you
have to hear what they're calling me the
girl who does nothing and he's like why
are you happy about that
because finally people get your brand i
know i was like this is so cute i love
it did you want us to do like games or
something i just thought there would be
some sort of structure or a plan
you've never watched a full episode like
that's why the cups are good i don't
watch any podcasts no i honestly
wouldn't expect it i think it would be
weird if we're like no anthony you are a
teeth grinder yes
did you ever hit up mary lou
i had not yet no maybe it should she'll
get more do you grind in your sleep or
just um
i sleep i like i can't relax and sleep
unless my teeth are completely clenched
it's sore i get botox in my jaw every
three months i've got like these uh i've
got two um
what do you call them
mouth guards yeah so they're like i
don't i can keep them forever because
they like they rub together so i don't
uh i don't bite down too hard but if i
went to sleep without them i would wake
up in pain that's what happened i fell
asleep without mine last night i smoked
too much weed and i fell asleep without
my mouth garden and my jaw is so [ __ ]
sore today i have a question when you do
i did the botox and jaw because my tmj
got really bad last year and i was like
oh i'll just try this but it completely
changed the way i smiled like my i had a
limit to how my smile yeah it would stop
right here
and i couldn't smile fully so i never
got it again but it worked with the pain
i noticed the smile is the same for me
uh but my jaw it changed the shape of my
jaw because from grinding so much these
muscles got bigger and the botox took
them down but since i have the beard it
wasn't that noticeable my face looks
thinner but do you do you wish you still
had the stronger jaw
no no wait so the botox actually works
it helps it's like it doesn't nothing
stops it i was looking for that magic
thing like i've gotten these crazy
massages and all kinds of different
stuff to try to take it away but it just
kind of mitigates it you know i work out
almost every day just to stretch and try
to take this like the tension out
because it goes all the way through my
body yeah but it's like whatever the
whatever your like
subconscious is gnawing at is the thing
it's like something subconsciously that
you're
i think it's muscle memory like i used
to do it when i was younger but it would
like i would go on and off do you
remember when you started doing it was
like was there any event in your life
that happened i remember i would do it
like in college you know people would
say like oh you're in your sleep you're
you're grinding your teeth a little bit
but it didn't i didn't feel it and then
i got to the point after college that i
got a mouth guard and then i just
stopped i would the mouth guard would
fall out in my sleep because i wasn't
doing it and then right before i did the
donald trump roast when i found out i
was gonna do that i was like this is my
big break i started doing it a lot
and i thought okay well let me get a
mouth guard now and then after it will
go away and then after the trump roast
when all the stress was gone i kept
doing it yeah and i've done it every day
since it's been like 13 14 years now you
guys do it every every night trump
mendenorial joint problem
because it's from trump tmj okay
no i think it's like muscle memory now
and like my teeth are so i've ground
them down so much that i i feel like i'm
trying to fit them together yeah you
know to what my teeth used to be yeah i
don't know i don't know what'll happen
but it's like it's the pebble in my shoe
it sucks yeah i know i can't stand it
yeah you get like inside massages where
they like go in there
i love that someone puts on some gloves
and puts their [ __ ] hands in my mouth
i'm like where else do you like it when
they put their hands
butt and your butt
have you guys ever done salvia
i never did but those videos of salva
are the most disgusting things i've ever
seen
had me do it because it's like you take
it you hit it like it's weed
and then you like go to another planet
for like 30 seconds like you look like
[ __ ] you look like [ __ ]
i came out of it and i felt great i was
like oh my god this is it was like
cleaning your windshield yeah and i was
like maybe i tried again and then i
watched the video of someone on it i was
like i'll never do this wait what do you
mean you look like [ __ ]
like you look like pull it yeah pull up
a video it's like it's dark it's dark
you're gone
but i've done ayahuasca and everyone's
always like worried about other people
looking at you you're not like it's not
you're you're there but you're not like
seeing it and then the the guides take a
little ayahuasca too so there's never
like a sober person actually it's like
you look
how long does the trip last
like it seems like it's it's one of
those like you feel like you're in a
dream yeah but it's it's literally like
45 maybe a minute 45 seconds a minute
but
uh i never did it again you should you
never did it again how did you stop
yourself from doing it again i mean it's
it's not that pleasant you don't feel
like i need i want to do this now it's
more an experience than like a
it's not like getting high where you're
just like i want to get high and watch a
movie it was like a
it was kind of tough that i did it once
a friend brought it over and i remember
coming out of the the trip my family
just had a huge smile on her face just
like i was like oh you just watched me
be real weird
yeah but maybe that's what you need to
break is that self-consciousness maybe
that's the thing that would
release you i like my self-consciousness
i feel like more people should be
self-conscious
right except i agree i agree with that
but also like duncan trussell posted the
best meme once and it was like you know
it was like
you know like a
spiritual being speaking to like an
audience yeah and it said once i
realized i was cringe i was free of
being cringe or something like there is
something where it's like when you're so
conscious of what's cringe yeah
i think that you could totally go too
far with self-consciousness there's no
doubt about that but i do think there's
like a
rein it in a little good amount i like
that i've never heard like a pro
self-conscious take but i'm actually
like yeah that's not a bad thing yeah
people are looking at us i mean we are
people that people
we stand and people look at us so it's
not well that's another there's also
that that's true
but like
well sometimes when esther's on stage
people are people are not looking
they're like where's
like where's this
i hear someone
they see brad williams walk past you
taller than him
oh brad
how pissed would brad be if they pass
another little person
at the store can you imagine
it would be a rivalry it would be fun i
would love it and put them right like
start giving them like the brad spots
and just put brad a little later you see
what happens
just a little like two people later oh
that's what they did with asians for so
long the scarcity mentality that's why
we that's why asian bobby is who he is
it's because that's what he wanted
and that fan and all these guys because
of scarcity mentality it's like there
can only be one of us guessing how to
fight you to the death you know so well
i guess they did that with like female
comics a little bit i never definitely
i never looked the same as any of them
it never like felt the same like i was
like next to you i had a female asian
comic open for me in vancouver and she
was great and i was like oh like what
are you like you're so funny what are
you gonna do and she's like nothing like
my career is over ali wong blew up and
it's over for me and i was like that's a
weird way to think about she's like no
it's it's how it is i gotta find
something else to do yeah she's wrong
that's right that's scarcity mentality
actually winning is the wait i think i
might know her was it was she um does
she have kids
no no this girl actually wasn't and you
know what this girl actually wasn't
she never seemed like she like i
remember talking her she's like no it's
just fine i just like to do these gigs
here and there i'm like really i can't
imagine doing comedy like
casually yeah someone could literally
take my name and like get plastic
surgery to look like me and like become
way i would never stop did you guys see
the plastic surgery in the comedy
community this week
no
no
uh
chris delia got a nose job shut up
shut up
how is that possible
what are you talking about how do you
know this todd told me was it to look
like me is today manifest i don't know
if they can put that much more on his
nose to make him wait wait
he got like he said it was a deviated
septum but it's a little
it's still swollen why would why would
you get married and then get a nose joe
i don't know
why do you think like deviated it's his
deviation i would believe
it's deviated septum because he's on a
podcast i think if you got a nose job
you would uh hide it you would hide it a
little better not in la i feel like
everyone almost like sports that thing
around like look i yeah yeah la is such
a weird place like everywhere i go
there's always someone with those
bandages under their nose but in comedy
i don't know like do you remember giving
like your first [ __ ] and like you
you tried to like not make sound i
remember trying to be like
so self-conscious like may as well have
been at a school dance
because i was i was my teacher i know
but like i just couldn't like i didn't
want to make any
sound i like wanted to be like really
like chill about it it just ended up
being like napkins i was like
am i fork
[Laughter]
but just trying and then i like watched
porn and i was like oh i went the
opposite direction you're supposed to
like
pretend to choke
have you ever puked on a deck esther
no i haven't but i'm not really a
thrower-upper
in general
constipation girl yeah yeah
sorry i feel like an anal joke i know
just getting packed up there
this does have like a sleepover vibe to
it that i feel like i'm like like
peeking in the door
[Music]
it's time to chat about liquid death you
know why is it called liquid death
because it's death to plastic ester and
10 of the profits from every can sold
are donated to help kill plastic
pollution you guys water and aluminum
cans is the future it tastes delicious
and liquid death has three new flavors
esther has a severed lime and he has the
what's it called mango
mango chainsaw mango chainsaw i have the
buried alive i love the lime i love so
much i don't drink you don't drink great
do any of us drink no hardly so it's
like we get to look cool at parties we
literally stay hydrated we're drinking
beer also i make mocktails at home with
this i do a little cranberry juice it's
so good and if you're anything like me
if you're anything like me and you're in
a social situation i'm like i never know
what to do with my hands this is the
perfect solution i'm actually not
kidding when i first got sober that was
such a big thing for me because
you don't realize how much you're using
a drink to get you through an awkward
social like the sip of it i remember
accidentally grabbing
cape cod before and like i had like
drank alcohol accidentally because it's
like you don't have the right thing to
grab well can i say the thing for me
that may seem so basic and cheesy but
like it makes drinking water fun and
then that makes me drink more water and
then that makes me prettier should i put
myself in a [ __ ] can so you do what i
want
guys it makes you pretty dehydrate so
get on it liquid death water and
aluminum death to plastic do it today
get free shipping on all water and merch
at liquid death dot com trash that's
liquiddeth.com
trash or you can find liquid death at
711 target albertson safeway or amazon
liquiddeth.com trash
[Music]
marin gave me advice when i met him and
he was like i met him like the first
week i was doing comedy at the comedy
store and he was just like get out of
here don't come here he was like go to
ucb he's like get away from the comedy
store oh my god that's so funny he got
me passed he was like you want an
audition
he told me to leave yeah people hang out
at the store too early they hang out at
clubs it's like you're not gonna like
you don't want to be known as the person
who hangs out you want to be the funny
person yeah they can't wait to get in
yeah but uh that's not bad advice so
maybe you should go to ucb no he gave me
good advice because at the time
the store was literally garbage and like
so shitty and no one should have been
there and the ucb was like the coolest
place to be but i just was had a
darkness and look at that now look at
where it is now
it's nowhere right it used to be
completely closed yeah i think they're
opening it back up i don't know it's not
gonna be the same i forget who bought it
well you look at those people too and
those people are still doing well in
acting and stuff like the sort of more
ucb comics i feel like but
a lot of people that i thought were
going to be like the big comics are like
no more
i remember they are that was the first
time i met you was at the comedy seller
i met you doing your podcast do you
remember the first time we met
i'm hoping you don't remember
oh no
the first time i remember meeting you
i'm really hoping last comic standing
oh with norm i don't remember that were
you a judge i know i was the host oh the
whole and
it was like the first night and i'm like
and i realize it's a mistake almost
immediately and i've done this and i'm
pissed i'm in a bad mood
and they're like will you
we want you to go in and talk to the
comics it was like there were like four
nights of like the preliminaries where
it's like these people now go on and it
becomes a competition but like come in
and talk to a room full of people and
i'm already i'm mad i'm doing it i'm mad
i got to do this i've got like i'm
trying to remember my lines in the
script and i'm like i walk in and i have
no plan of what i'm going to say to
everyone so i'm kind of just like guys
don't shake my hand on stage like i'm
just like i'm just almost like yelling
at people and i walk in
angry nervous
and esther goes
she's sitting on like in a chair on the
floor next to me and she goes and i'm
like any questions and asked he goes
anthony will you get me pregnant
oh you used to be so funny and i wanted
to remember that
what happened to the little rape joke
esther remember you want to kill me wait
that's so oh my god i can't believe i
said i was mad that anyone would even
talk to me i was just i was so mad i was
there
and anyone trying to joke around with me
i was pissed i don't remember saying
that so that's at least but we can all
see it but one hundred percent i'm sure
i i i wouldn't say it i'm like of course
i did that
i remember i will say this like
because it's so easy to have to be
cheesy in that role of being the host
and i do you never
were like cheesy or betrayed yourself
like you were very like you were cool it
was you you were in character as
yourself like you stay true to yourself
so at least i have that to say i
remember i was that was when i first met
miss pat and she was like
she was like talking about how she
wanted to beat the [ __ ] out of me
she was like if you were my child and
telling me like how she wanted to hit me
and i was like thank you miss pat um
but do you remember the what happened
with norm mcdonald how he was like
really nasty to me
he was nasty to a lot of people okay i
mean do you like norman i would fight
oh fight on camera really and after
every episode we would meet up and we'd
he'd be like well it's going to be great
television because it was like they're
like you guys need to talk this out
because he would be so mean and the
audience was like what so i would come
and come back at norm try to get the
audience back and then he was getting
mad about me coming back at him none of
the judges were used to thought the host
was going to be mean to them yeah and so
i was like i'm on the comic side yeah
i'm going to be mean to you and it was
just it was so uncomfortable the whole
thing well that was what that was why i
felt so tricked because the producers
were like hey we're doing this
differently it's not like simon cowell
vibes like it's going everyone's a comic
here we're gonna be really it's all
positive constructive so everyone was
going in like we're not expecting a
fight and then when norm would like
suddenly say rude [ __ ]
i
reacted honestly in the moment i was
like
i'm not taking this so yeah that is my
memory you guys fought a lot yeah did he
lose that fight too
um
i took the job because i wanted to work
with norm so they were like no one's not
happy with you and i'm like i'm not
happy with him i don't know what's going
on here it was so he was so he's a
little bit like but in a weird way
wasn't he always like you couldn't tell
if he was doing a bit or not that's how
i always felt when i i mean the bits
didn't make sense it wasn't a bit it was
like he was pontificating about things
and female comics especially got it got
it right
and and it didn't make he would love
someone and hate someone else and didn't
make that there was no rhyme or reason
that it was just awkward and weird and
he would go on for a long time yeah but
i felt like i had to kind of not roast
him but i had to kind of take control of
the show otherwise it was like the norm
the norm hour and i think roseanne and
keenan were like what's he doing yeah
what's norm talking about yeah it was
real weird when roseanne's going is this
guy crazy you know there's an issue
i remember he said something like it's
calling me like the biggest
disappointment of his night and i was
like that's so daddy
why are you like i can't disappoint you
i know i think i said something like
you're my dad's favorite comic or like i
don't know it was just so awkward it was
so weird and then afterwards i was
freaking out
oh i had to comfort like there were
people crying afterwards and i'd be like
don't let them see you cry like [ __ ]
last comic standing like i'm the best
comic in three a three mile radius and i
wouldn't make it three minutes on this
show like why wasn't anyone upset
i was just i hated the process i know so
much nice to comics yeah but for the
most part yeah there was one girl i
remember this girl got introduced by her
father like i introduced everyone but
there's one they're like her dad's here
they were like an indian family and the
dad came out with a heavy accent was
like i'm so proud of my daughter and she
walks out like a really nice dress does
three minutes and then norm says i go
norm what do you think and norm goes
what the hell is going on here i was
told i'd be here to judge the hundred
funniest people in the country i don't
think you're one of the hundred funniest
people in this room
i lost it so hard i thought it was the
funniest thing i've ever heard like her
dad's right there he knows that it's so
funny to be mean to someone in front of
their parents
it's actually nice it's like
they'll fix this he could be funny and
if it was funny great but there were a
lot of times he wasn't being funny it
was just like why are you being so mean
to this like hack comic who you can just
dismiss and be like yeah not my thing
you know he always said he didn't like
crazy female comedians right didn't you
say he didn't think women in front of
you yeah that is so [ __ ] annoying
yeah he had some uh he had some opinions
though like what
how are we doing this yes it's banana
break time are you a banana fan
i mean sure like i'm a fan
[Music]
well are you um are you a comment reader
or just was there were so many comments
that you can't i mean you can't ignore
it when you're getting like indeed i
read them
peruse them because they all become the
same all the negative ones are the same
all the positive ones the same but
occasionally there's one that's like my
parents address and i'm like
let me take that one down yeah but i see
things yeah i i'm aware of what's going
on but yeah they all are they're all the
same yeah
speaking of comments there's i saw on
reddit i'll occasionally glance this one
oh that's a real cutting moment this one
really caught my eye but there's someone
on reddit
who is saying who's
comparing you to tony hinchcliffe
and i'm like is there something
is there something there like they're
calling me skinny
because i'm like i don't know if you
know this fact about me but i dated tony
a long long time i already said he
regretted coming on the show
you're giving him more reasons
but i'm like is there something like are
you
is there something about me being drawn
to you and tony that
i mean what how could i be like tony
in what way could i be like tony that
i'm attracted to you oh
i just started saying c word
i love asians
when i first met you i think i think
bobby and i must have been pacing around
the house for a good like hour before
just because he like builds these things
in my head where he's like you know he's
he's this way and he's that way and he's
this way
and um
you couldn't have been more different
than what he what did he say
you know like bobby has like a healthy
fear of people with principle
like and you are a person who is like
principled like things like you know you
you you're in comedy it's the wild wild
west and there are few people who really
sort of like know who they are and
you're like you know what there is right
from wrong i'm not going to play this
[ __ ] wild wild west game and he views
you as that because he plays in the wild
wild west so he kind of felt like oh god
like um i'm gonna get it talking to
basically but he did he get you you were
that was you were the one that brought
up the megan gayle the mega daily stuff
yeah
i didn't know that what i was i brought
her up and i forgot about that they had
any kind of issue at all yeah but that
worked out because
megan came on our show and then bobby
bought her like a flat screen tv
like i mean he spent three thousand
dollars on all of these gifts to give
her like every 10 minutes of that show
he was like here's another gift
because he was so embarrassed about how
he conducted himself and the reason that
he even came to that reckoning was
because you basically put him in his
place he was and you're like yeah you
you were an [ __ ] to her what did he
do to her again he like kicked out of
the green room or something he had i
think she
did the power moves he was like i don't
like what you're wearing on stage oh
that's it's my show [ __ ] up and that's
the most [ __ ] up thing to say
that's so [ __ ] up and i love her she's
so funny though why would he do that
because he's a [ __ ]
yeah i mean she wasn't like a ball gown
or something right like it was kind of
like
i might have been she's the emcee like
who gives a [ __ ] like maybe be annoyed
but to to open yourself up to be like
this upsets me
it's cl i think he was upset about other
things
maybe his set wasn't so good and then he
wanted to be like it must have been the
dress i think that's always good but i
think before shows he'll he thinks the
worst yeah is there nothing
that enrages you more than when people
ask a question and then 10 minutes after
when you don't answer the question right
away text you like 20 question marks oh
i i never will talk to them again i
appreciate that to me
i kind of know what you mean but no one
they wouldn't dare
yeah that's a block
you
don't care if people don't like you
you've just never cared
i try to do things and if i'm gonna be
mean i try to do it in a very concise
way that it's like
you kind of have to laugh and respect it
but i'm not
i've said some like really mean stuff
but it's like you i've got to give you
some rope you know it was a comic who
just kept giving me advice
this is like a couple months ago just
kept being like oh you should do this as
a podcast just do this and i'm like
trying to be played for as long as i can
and finally i'm like if i need any more
career advice i'll let you know and the
room laughs and i was like oh yeah i'm
yeah you're right i'm sorry and
everyone's like that was really funny
i'm like i didn't i wasn't trying to be
mean but he like didn't give me any
choice yeah yeah you have to shoot
people down how do you have like that
confidence and self-worth and stuff to
be like yeah if someone sent me those
question marks i'd block them like where
does that come from that you're like you
just do you know yourself so well or
like what is that
a combination of things maybe i just get
away with it but if you want to accept
the consequences you don't let it bother
you then you can kind of do anything i
am so
afraid of blocking people like i'm just
there's something about that i just have
like this big hump with it like i'm so
afraid that i don't know like like i'll
miss an emergency or like i will have
done something so bad it just but i want
so badly to be that person that's just
like no you're you're even if you block
someone if they need to get a hold of
you they can still find a way to get a
hold of you but see i don't i'll block
on twitter you mute on twitter because i
don't want them to have the satisfaction
of knowing they're blocked unless i want
them to know i think owen benjamin years
ago i was like i want you to know that i
did i like dislike you and
uh i'm blocking you but on on texts i
want to know what's coming yeah if some
crazy person is like blowing up my phone
i want to know if they're about to show
up at the show you know that i wouldn't
i wouldn't block that but i wouldn't
respond okay i'll leave you on red i uh
yeah leaving on red is the power move
i don't blo i've unfollowed a lot of
people
that i see a lot that feels good
that is because don't they just like
evaporate from your consciousness
you know what's a fun move is uh if
someone's texting you right back like oh
my god i'm [ __ ] dealing with
so and so somebody was just we're
talking about and uh and they're so
[ __ ] annoying send it to them and
then right back sorry that was for
someone else
that's a that's a brutal move wait about
that's so so if it was me if you're
texting me a bunch i'll just write back
oh that's just being so [ __ ] annoying
right now and then right back oh sorry
for someone else
that'll [ __ ] your whole week up all
right that i'm into that
well i feel like i sometimes
when people are like there was this one
girl that i unfollowed she was bothering
me she wanted me to do an uh voice on
her cartoon and she's like not a thing
like i don't someone drew her a cartoon
it's like nothing i was like i don't
want to be on your cartoon so i just
ignored her
and then um she was complaining to my
friend like oh annie's like not
responding to me or whatever so when i
see her next time i'm gonna go why do
you think i'm not responding to you
and see if she can come up with it
because it's like if you're if you ask
me if you've contacted me three times in
a row and it's you asking me to do
something for you you've not offered me
anything there's no exchange i will
never talk to you again
see i'm i like tiffany haddish is so
good at this when i was doing a show
with her and someone's like hey tiffany
are we doing a quick video and she goes
i get paid a lot of money to make movies
and it's like it's like a way she's
staying with a smile they're enjoying
the the conversation there's no like
comments it's not like that's a boundary
i like to say of course i'm not going to
do that yeah
oh that is good yeah gives you an out
like no one's mad and it's so easy okay
wait i love that so that's like what i'm
seeking in life i know this sounds weird
but someone who when i ask them
something that they'll say of course i'm
not going to do that because it's so
sick it makes me feel so secure that
you're never going to do something that
you don't want to do for me if you're
like maybe you know let me think about
it like don't do that just say of course
i'm not going to do that
that's great i think that's the freedom
when i look at you there's a freedom
that i don't need to speculate about
where we stand
yes yeah i had someone ask me like do
you hate me and i'm like do you know
people i hate and they're like yeah i'm
like do they have to ask me if i hate
them
you're right
i'll let you know
i'm so inspired i want to be like this i
just like it so much i don't know i feel
like it's there's something in me that
can it's it's in there i can learn so
much from you because i've just been a
chronic people pleaser my whole life and
super cool yeah
and i um i have a problem telling people
or just rocking the boat in general so i
feel like you are the perfect person
after a ketamine hole you have to just
own it and not regret it and so that way
you get a reputation where someone's
like he was such a [ __ ] dick like
that's just anthony you know
he just roasts people it's it's fine
yeah no one can get that mad it's i'm
glad you're saying that because it is
reminding me of what we learned about
you and how you are people pleaser and
it's hard for you to say no
and like
i would love i would literally get off
on hearing you say to me of course i'm
not doing that i would love for you to
say that to me in in my ketamine journey
yesterday do you know what i found out i
was asking
this is how codependent i was in my own
[ __ ] as i'm seeing mossy cave after
mossy cave
apparently i was repeating this is
everyone okay
are you okay i was saying the therapist
name are you okay i'm worried about i'm
worried about you hey is everyone okay
i'm like the [ __ ] that's something
deep-rooted [ __ ] that's exactly what
needs to be happening because you have
to get through that you have to keep
doing that until you stop doing it yeah
that's the truth i want to get to the
point where i'm like
i don't care who's okay and who's not
okay how about okay why don't we do a
challenge that why don't we do a
challenge maybe a blocking challenge or
like
respond right away with an honest
opinion for a while yeah yeah challenge
but see
the other side of that is that is
i can be very cutting and my truth the
way i feel inside
is oftentimes not what people can handle
and people see me as this like very
complacent
placating type of person
but if you're asking for that it can get
ugly real fast because my feelings the
deep burning feelings in my chest
aren't pretty oh no it's just going to
be like esther you're ugly
when she was ugly for me when she was
saying that she was like in the pod and
she's like you know what i was thinking
were you like was it about me were you
hoping she was gonna say like i thought
about you
but yes you are you are my goals when i
i'm gonna put you in my vision board as
somebody who has very firm boundaries
and just who just is principled and is
you know
very um
we can rely on you for the truth
so i i want to be that person of course
i'm not doing that of course i'm not
going to do that but my new favorite is
uh the guy at the comedy store the
photographer at the comedy store will be
like hey can i get you to do some poses
in the bathroom and i go i don't have
time for your [ __ ] tonight
and he laughs she's like all right cool
got it and it's like there's no
it's not awkward it's just like there's
no guessing
as a slug he watches what's up man
van um is doing great but if he puts one
of those [ __ ] dots on my picture i
will block my i will black my name off
the wall
what do you mean he he everyone he
hasn't done in a while but every once in
a while he'll put like add like these
dots onto the pictures and it's i'm onyx
i find it unacceptable they're like
little bubbles like white i didn't
notice them for the longest time and
someone pointed them out i thought on
tony baker i'm like leave tony baker
alone all right it's not ben who asked
me to pose but it's the other guy i got
with the beard oh matt yeah matt matt do
you watch yeah they're both good though
the store photographers are good i'm my
favorite thing and shout out to your
girlfriend liz who's seriously freaking
so amazing
amazing we gotta get her to the comedy
store can we get it i know i'm trying
really i'll have to
yeah i want her there it's kind of it's
the thing now where they're like yeah we
want you and then no one ends up getting
in touch and she's like what's going on
they're like oh they haven't gotten
touched yet we'll talk to someone but
like the shore brother whatever was like
was like yeah let's get her number and
get her in here so hopefully
something works out yeah cause she's at
the laugh factory mostly and then at
large she left the laugh actually she'd
be improv now
yeah oh she is
i've heard that your dog has more
followers on instagram than you is that
true i just started an instagram like
like a month ago and i've got two posts
and i'm about to hand it over to a
social media guy that i just kind of did
it to that's like the future is
instagram and tick tock and i've always
avoided that stuff but i i started the
the accounts but i i made one for my dog
when i got him a couple years ago and uh
he's got like almost 10 000 followers
that's like my passion like i love the
dog instagram i hate and i've learned
that if i'm in the picture with the dog
it gets way more likes um that i uh i've
been doing more of those but does that
make you feel good when you're like you
need me dog i think that should be your
main instagram account then like it
should just be like you sometimes use
your dog's account to promote
stuff i thought about that if i wasn't
if i was just using it for like fun i
would do that but if i'm going to sell
tickets oh one of those will happen
under my name yeah
bring the dog with you go full female
comic
he's too big bring oh he's a big gun oh
so cute i like the name of your largo
show it's funny just looking enemies
yeah
it is funny though everyone's like is
jasmine does he hate me is he thinking
talking [ __ ] on me and you're just like
posting pictures of your dog
oh
do you have other tips for like i'm
trying to have a dog a self-worth summer
like how to build your self-worth so
that you say no to people and like
have boundaries
i just when i really hate something i
think like why did i say yes to this and
now i've learned like i just got offered
to do a new year's eve gig that sounded
like something sounded great and things
didn't i was like you know what i
guarantee come new year's eve and like
why did i do this i don't want to be
getting on this plane right now and so i
just said no well in advance that just
when you don't like something think like
should i what why didn't i say no you
just start saying no to things yeah like
i turned down
most podcast appearances i was
interested to see what this would be
like
would you come back
would you come back
sure
it's not that far away like i like you
guys i i thought this was uh
interesting i feel like i this isn't a
healthy feeling but i feel like you're
one of my papas of comedy because you
talked to me when i was an open miker
so i seek your approval but i mean you
scheduled an appointment it wasn't like
you just walked up
you scheduled an appointment no i know
you and you
like followed through and you showed up
i it sounds like i sexually harassed you
at work
so thank you for forgiving me
i remember i left at that night and i
was talking to a friend of mine and i
was like do you know esther pavitski she
said and they go before you say anything
she's a friend of mine and i was like oh
i'm not like that's i'm not saying
anything bad like that's it i forget
i forget esther needs to know
no it's that's nice yeah
proud of you for that moment though that
is a very like strong esther move
to ask him to get me pregnant yeah yeah
yeah it's very on brand it's very on
brand well you're tall like you have
like the right opposing things for my
genetics that would
it's i like how you're justifying this
like you were seriously trying to get
pregnant
like you weren't making
i talked to my dad about it
he's here he's gonna introduce me i
don't make jokes
i just say things that sometimes are
funny i do feel like i met you like you
when i first met you you were like
already kind of blowing up you had
already had your mtv
um unpicked up pilot you're unpicked up
but that was a big deal for the level
that all of us were at at that point
and um
but and then you started you were like
i think just getting into acting and
stuff so you were being like i think
more
like behaved
you weren't as like tits out you were
you were on the end of your tits out
phase i don't know i think i've always
been like silly and stuff but i
definitely had periods of time in this
career or whatever like my adulthood
where i've been more shy and not fully
myself
and i feel like that is something that
like discovering weed has been helpful
with that i think that's why i'm so
curious about like
all the other kinds of psychedelic stuff
because
yeah i feel like a part of me
got lost in
[Music]
whatever it is like the pressures of
work and stuff but i think that's what
happens to everyone like you get older
and you like the world tells you to shut
up or this and that and then you like
dim yourself or whatever well also you
just naturally like settle into yourself
and maybe the things that were like
activating you beforehand i watch a lot
of reality tv and
i've watched the
mtv's challenge for since it started
we got theo has to talk about it why
does he never talk about it have you
ever tried to talk he was on a road
doesn't like talking about it doesn't
like being brought up i get the road
rules part of it because he wants to
know as a comedian but the challenge was
only i i didn't even watch the season
yeah but i got into it during the
pandemic and was like all about it yeah
i haven't watched the new the last
season or two well i watched the first
two seasons all-stars i'm very happy to
know you like it it's good but the thing
is with all stars is what i was gonna
say is so they have it's been going on
for 20 some years and so all of the
people and the challenges all of the
people from the railroad and the world
wars are used to be now it's different
reality shows too come and they do all
these like really insane hard
physical competitions and they get voted
off and stuff but
now they're older so no one's really
like [ __ ] each other no one's really
like drinking no one's really getting
wasted or fighting so it's definitely a
different thing and then now they're
trying to sort of reinvent it with with
younger people and they had to make the
challenges easier because
no one could compete could complete them
they're all like in their 50s now what
other reality shows are you into
i mean i watched during the pandemic i
never watched anything but i got into
the challenge big time when i was going
back and watching seasons and like oh my
god the storyline is great from like
three years ago
i watched um big brother i wish couple
seasons of big brother watching the new
season now i haven't watched the new
season either uh i don't know if i will
uh that i watched the bachelor last
season uh-huh and uh i've watched the
first episode of bachelorette but i
truly hated it oh is it this did it just
start the bachelorette i like gabby
though yeah the new i really like her
who was the last bachelorette was
michelle
oh yeah it was michelle yeah i feel like
the last couple of seasons of the
bachelor sometimes it's just i don't
know it's just such an unbelievable show
it's like so like the
people are also
like full of [ __ ]
yeah but um yeah i didn't watch this
first episode i don't know what what
it's gonna be like with the two girls no
one's in too long
i watched the first season of survivor
ever i just moved to l.a i remember
being really into it and then just
didn't they started the new season like
right afterwards and i was like i can't
i can't do this it's my favorite thing
about it they don't wait that long which
means my favorite show i freak out when
i've ran into jeff ropes and it's
it's you would think i i'm you know
meeting oprah or something i freaked out
he's my guy
he's the man would you ever do a reality
show like that
no
i just don't i don't want to be on
camera the whole time i don't like
i don't want people to see me run yeah
like i i uh
i enjoy watching them but yeah i don't
feel the need to to be a part of that um
you guys thank you so much for tuning in
thank you to anthony for sitting here
being polite
and um you guys will see you next week
with a whole new episode with anthony
we're gonna have him back
he said it's close but honestly he's the
only male comic who will agree to do our
show after our [ __ ] went down so thank
you because no one wants to [ __ ] talk
to us anymore you did not tell me that
when you asked me
[Music]
you